hello hi everyone
this is michael talking from the cfp
team and there is catherine
hello
good morning afternoon everybody evening
good evening good night whatever time it
is
um yeah so thanks everybody uh who i
guess is struggling in to watch uh
office hours
so we're here today um to just answer
any questions you might have about the
call for proposals the proposal
submission process julie account in
general
um
so if you want to ask a question just
post it in the youtube chat and we can
bring it up on screen and answer any
questions
oh we're live on pi data too nice
yes
love to see
yeah so maybe while we wait we can just
talk a little bit about the current
status of submissions so things are
slowly
ramping up as we see so people
are probably finishing up their
proposals in the last minutes so in case
you guys have not yet finished it then
basically
uh don't feel worried about it i think
you're still in the majority of the
crowd
all right
okay so a few questions are slowly
dripping in
shall we get going with the first yeah
let's do it
all right so
that was the wrong clicked that's what i
wanted to go for so the first question
is by alex jones how long roughly will a
successful proposal be how much detail
to go into
um
yeah i think basically uh the a good
length for proposal is really to
explain what you want to talk about to
give the reason for the
uh for the for the julia community to be
interested in that topic um i don't
think that necessarily needs to be the
full 5000 characters but it should sort
of give an overview of the
of the content and basically the
relevance i think those are really the
main points
and i guess you can say that in a few
paragraphs
uh the one thing i would add to that is
if you're giving a talk about something
that's like a little more domain
specialized so like for example i've
given talks about physics before and not
everybody going to juliacon as a
physicist
so it can be helpful just to also
include a little bit of information like
not only for the reviewers but for
people who might
who want to watch your talk about like
um like what what's sort of the
relevance of your specific domain like
package or example
um just to the wider julia community um
yeah so sort of to summarize it's not so
much the length that counts but more
that the content is really uh yeah
making it clear to people what is
happening yeah
yeah great
i can do the next one so we had a
question um
i wonder if i can present in spanish um
even if the paper isn't english so the
answer is yes um you are welcome to give
your talk uh since they're gonna be
pre-recorded
in in multiple languages or in one
specific language and that language does
not have to be english um
so we are asking people you can also
submit your your proposal in another
language but we ask that you also
provide an english translation this year
just for ease of review
um
but yeah you're very welcome to present
your your talk in another language just
please if you want to do that make a
note in the abstract so that we know
um if your talk or proposal is accepted
that we can just put in in the program
this talk is going to be presented in x
y and z languages so in this case maybe
spanish um just so people if they're if
they're really interested in watching
spanish language talks or they don't
speak spanish they can um you know be
forward before the tech
and on that note we are definitely still
looking for people to review proposals
in the future so especially when it
comes to non-english languages where our
review pool is not so established yet so
if you are not just only interested in
proposing a talk but also maybe in
reviewing another talk in
another proposal in spanish and of
course that goes to everyone in the
audience for whatever language they
speak we're definitely looking for
reviewers in uh non-english languages so
that would be really appreciated
so
yeah then maybe let's go for the next
one
let's go for this one here
the question again by alex is alex jones
would you consider pde solvers as quite
domain specific
i guess if you really talk about pde
solvers on the general level i would not
necessarily call that domain specific
because
yeah i mean the julia community is
really quite centered around
computing and high performance computing
and scientific problems in particular
and pdes i would personally consider a
recurring theme so you don't necessarily
need to explain what a pde is for
example to the julia community but of
course if your solver has specific
features that are only occurring in your
computational domain then i would say
this is something that you might need to
emphasize to make sure that people
understand why this specific feature is
relevant
so we have another one um this is
actually a question that that i feel
like a lot of people have um how can i
know if i should aim for the 10 minute
talk or the 30 minute talk um so thanks
for asking this martin because i'm sure
a lot of people are wondering this um
so one thing um that i would say is if
if you have like a strong idea already
of what it is you want to say then you
can one thing i actually have done in
the past when i asked myself a similar
question is literally just practice the
talk
and time it um and i don't know if other
people have this problem but usually
when i practice talks i talk really
really really fast because i'm anxious
and nervous so just remember you know if
you practice your talk and it comes in
at like
like 13 minutes you could probably
actually turn that into a 30-minute talk
if you know you talk slower
and and build in a little bit more time
for questions and stuff like that um
so it i mean it's up to you the other
thing is that we can also like when we
review
the proposals if we see something that
looks like somebody submitted for the 10
minute talk but it looks like they have
like so much material that it would make
more sense as a 30-minute talk we can
kind of shift it between the two streams
um so if you're not sure
you're not you're not handcuffing
yourself to a specific talk length um
but my my advice would be yeah uh try
just going through and like practicing
like what you would can imagine yourself
saying about the talk and that should
give you some idea
um
i think another another way to tell is
like if you haven't have like a involved
demo you want to do or in general if you
have a demo i think a 30-minute talk is
better um just because demos always take
longer than you think
um
and if you have more than like the most
simple example i think a 30 minute talk
is the is a better way to present it um
so that's my voice
i think i think something to add is also
if this topic you're talking about is a
topic that is not so much established in
the julia community so sort of where
you're introducing a new scientific
field or something it might really be
worth to spend the time of introducing
the field by itself uh even if it's not
completely the the actual focus of the
talk you want to have um just to make it
available to the community and tell
people why it's relevant and get them a
little bit interested and i think for
that spending five to ten minutes of
just introduction is completely worth it
and that would also in my opinion then
tend and lean more towards a 30 minute
talk and of course sort of the other end
of the scale would be a topic that
everybody in the jewelry community knows
and then you can more or less skip the
introduction and that would sort of lean
more towards a focused 10 minute talk in
my opinion
maybe let's check the next one here
so uh jacob asked that he is us
basically
in short whether he needs to sort of
prove knowledge of his expertise
um
i would say in general we are not so
much doing that
i mean if you for example have a paper
or something that is relevant to your
work it could be worth just adding the
reference to make it clear for reviewers
um but that you are basically uh yeah
that you are really an expert talking
about it but in general i think it's
less that you really have to prove
expertise it should be clear to the
reviewers that you know what you're
talking about from the description such
that they can have a judgment on that
but the the the yeah the main the key
emphasis point for julia corn is less
the expertise it's really more the
specificity for the community and the
usefulness in general to the community
so logan asked should we include links
to our package if you're talking about
one so um in general i think it's a good
idea like for example if you're
introducing a new package
for um just off the top of my head
plotting it's helpful to include a link
to the package um so that for example
like the the reviewers for the program
can just go look and see like what level
of development the package is at
um
so we we do
for
the review process try and blind reviews
so that nobody's name is associated with
a proposal when it's reviewed to try and
remove bias um so of course if you
include a link to your package it's a
little bit de-anonymizing so it's up to
you you don't have to
include a link to your package but
in general it can help um especially if
your package is like like you're
introducing a new package um or as we've
mentioned earlier like if it's domain
specific in maine that not a lot of
people are familiar with um it could
help to just show like this package
really exists it does test you know
people are using it there's like a
computer community there's example
notebooks stuff like that um so it's up
to you uh
but i would say for yeah for new
packages or domain specific ones it can
be helpful
yeah and the next talk is once again
from uh the next questions once again
from martin as a follow-up um so he's
noticed that 30 minutes talks are
generally for packages that have a
general audience when 10 minutes are
more for niche topics is this true
um
i'm not entirely sure so i i remember so
the first talk i did at julia cohn for
example about basically quantum
chemistry package written in julia that
was
i would say that is pretty much a niche
topic nevertheless it was a 30 minute
talk so that is certainly
a counter example i would say
i
guess
i mean sort of in line with what i said
that that new topics tend to tend to
take longer to explain
to some extent this is a little bit true
that the 10 minutes talks are really
about the specific package doing one
specific task whereas the 30 minute ones
are therefore more bit of an overview uh
have more of an overview um
yeah content i guess
but i i don't i don't think there's this
general tendency what are you thinking
yeah um i mean so my experience was like
uh
i think in julie khan
2019 yes um so
matt fishman and i gave a 30-minute talk
about this package eyetencers.jail that
we are working on and that was like a
pretty niche topic like it's very
focused on people doing computational
physics um but because we were
introducing the package and then doing
demos and then also talking about like
the design decisions we made when
building the package
um it was a good fit for a 30-minute
talk um
versus yeah um you know if we had just
been
just been introducing the package
without a demo without talking about
like
specific design choices we made then a
10-minute talk might have been a better
fit
so i wouldn't i wouldn't necessarily
assume that if your topic is like niche
somehow um that attempted attack is the
only place it can go
so for sure i would not say that like
niche topics are not worthy for a
30-minute talk or something like that
this is definitely not true it's it's
really about the the yeah the the sort
of overview you want to give or the sort
of topic you want to the sort of content
you want to present that determines
whether it's a 10 or 30 minute talk and
it's not whether the community consider
this relevant to to be given a 30-minute
talk um yeah i think i think that's
that's not so much that should really
not be your guiding factor yeah
all right so again martin has another
follow-up talk uh is it possible to
change the type of the talk you applied
for yeah sure i mean
it's it's possible i mean skt
sorry as kate said it's basically like
i mean there's still some possibility
during the review process to change it
and um i think
until we do the scheduling it's pretty
flexible right so if you for example
have the feeling that a 10 minute talk a
30 minute talk is too much to prepare i
guess it can be shortened to 10 minutes
i don't i don't necessarily see a
problem there
uh so logan has another question um
what's the best talk type for new julia
users who aren't domain experts yet um
so i think this is kind of the whole
reson detroit of the um experiences talk
type so for folks who are familiar julia
experiences are for people who are
newcomers to the julia community and
there are sort of shorter talks about um
like your experiences learning julia
maybe you took julia in a class or
you're learning it for work um or just
for your interest and so experiences
talks are about like it says
sort of what your impressions of julia
have been as a newcomer like maybe from
another language maybe it's your first
programming language um things you like
things you don't like things that would
be helpful for you as a newcomer to the
julia community
also like things you like or don't like
about the julie community itself
um so i would definitely recommend uh
folks who are newcomers submit to the
experiences track um even if it's like
your first day learning julia those are
some of the best experiences talks we
get so please don't feel that like
you're not qualified to give a talk like
that or something um
we really want to encourage everybody
who's a member of the community to
consider uh submitting talks especially
to the experiences track
in fact i guess you all know this
if you have already spent some time
doing a certain topic let's say julia
for example then you forget about the
problems because you sort of either have
gotten used to them or you i don't know
you sort of just consider them part of
the game or
cannot be changed or something and i
think i mean for us as a community it's
really really important to see what
people struggle with and what people
find actually also interesting what
motivated them to to really get into the
topic and get into the into julia and
yeah so therefore actually i would also
really encourage people to give talks
even though they're new and exactly tell
us about these aspects tell us about
what annoys you and what you like
well
other questions
all right so uh the first stream has cut
off but please feel free to ask more if
you have
something on your mind
oh here we have a question again from
martin why is there a special track for
the jump packages
um
so
uh my understanding of why this is the
jump has had their sort of own
conference for a long time um at
jump.dev and this year they're
they're having a conference track like
sort of simultaneously or it's like sort
of under the umbrella of the wider julia
con um so because job has its own
community that kind of mostly interacts
with jump um it was decided that they
would have like their own sort of
conference stream just so for people who
are like extremely interested in jump
they could just know where to go you
know have all jump all the time um but
definitely if you are not a job expert
like i actually know very little about
it but i'm probably gonna watch some
talks just like find out what's going on
over there um
so if you're at all interested in like
what the heck is going on with jump um
i'm sure they would be happy to have
people attend their talks and ask
questions
yeah and then there's the next one
coming up by alex again any advice for
first time speakers in terms of pacing
and content
i guess
for speaking in a conference and
especially when it's pre-recorded what
is quite important that cannot be
understated is really that you that you
don't speak too fast
and you really go step by step because
unlike a verge like unlike a physical um
presentation people don't really have
the chance to interrupt you so i think
it's really important to sort of be
clear in the arguments in in what you're
presenting and rather take it slow than
too fast also because people can ask
questions but they have to type them
on a chat system and you will probably
be around to answer them but then when
they're typing them they cannot actually
listen to the to what is going on in the
youtube video and so therefore i think
it's it's really important to not
not try to to do too much and put too
much content in your in your talk
yeah
um another thing i guess i would add for
for first time speakers in general um
emperor for any speaker is just don't
don't um overestimate the amount of
familiarity people have uh with your
specific domain area i really struggle
with this actually when i give talks at
julia khan because normally when i give
talks it's to an audience of people who
are like um have a lot of physics
background or a lot of um
like certain kinds of cs background like
hpc background so one thing that's
really great about the julia community
is that there's people from all kinds of
different like academic or
industry backgrounds people have
expertise in a lot of different things
but um
that can also mean that you you really
need to like set the stage at the start
of your talk like this is my talk is
about let's say like statistical methods
for biology um and
we're going to be talking about
implementation of these techniques in
this talk so if you're not familiar with
these here's like a quick two-minute
introduction to what they are and what
they try to accomplish um i'm not going
to give a specific example because i'm
not a biologist i'd probably say
something really dumb
um but
i think yeah it can be very helpful for
people just kind of give them an on-ramp
in in the first few like slides of your
talk or your workshop or whatever even
so they can just decide like is it worth
it for me to
stay here and keep watching because
maybe this isn't my specific area but i
can still learn something from this talk
or like like i'm not gonna connect with
this at all i'm just gonna you know this
this person sounds cool and it sounds
like what they're doing is very
interesting but this is not for me
um
cool
yeah
um and then we have a question from
patrick which i'll put up are there any
plans for physical catch-ups in the
future or will things remain virtual for
now
uh so we do have some plans to allow
people
to host like local meetups during julia
con so obviously you know this is going
to depend on the situation in your area
like the pandemic is still ongoing and
different places have different
restriction levels and people have
different comfort levels with meeting up
in person
um
but if you're interested in hosting like
a local meetup um you know like for one
afternoon or one evening
at your local area during the conference
um get in touch with the organizing
community because we may be able to
offer some support like you know like
buy pizza or something um or like if you
need to pay a fee to reserve space in
like a bar or something like that um so
if you're interested in helping to
organize a local meetup we actually do
have somebody who is coordinating that
so please feel free to send an email to
the organizing committee and we can put
you in touch with that person
also maybe a general comment because i'm
not sure how general you mentioned the
question um in fact there are already a
number of meetups like regular meetups
all around the world which are related
to julia
they coordinate at meetup.com some at
the discourse forum and so on and so
forth so in case you're generally
interested to get in touch with the
julia community or in the area around
you just essentially have a google
search and i'm pretty sure you will find
something
yeah that is also a possibility to get
in touch and talk with people physically
about julia
yeah so logan has a follow-up uh to
build on alex question suggestions to to
record like tools to record the talk and
make sure the quality is good so
i
don't recall the details but every i
think for last year's julia con there
has been um
no actually already for two years ago
there has been
a great to do video by by jane right
okay do you remember yeah exactly by
jane which has been uploaded to youtube
which basically walks you through um
some screen recording software that
actually i forgot the name osm obs open
broadcast studio probably exactly obs
yes you're right it was obs which was um
so i have never actually done any
recording before i recorded my junior
con talk and i managed to do it so it is
it is possible and actually not too hard
so this obs studio it's a really really
nice talk um by jane who really walks
you through the steps to do it and gives
you also some general recommendations
for like light uh
how to sit how to place yourself in the
room um
some ideas for like microphone for
example how you make sure that you're
audible um
yeah so that is something that i would
really recommend to watch and then
just follow the general guidelines so i
think it worked okay for me yeah
yeah i would really recommend obs which
is um a open source software which is
cool and then b it works on most
operating systems so whether you're
windows linux or mac user um it should
work for you the other thing that i
found very helpful in the past when
recording talks i've given is just like
record the talk like three or four times
and then you can pick between the best
one so if you if you if you go through
it you're like oh that was terrible just
re-record it it's not a big deal yeah
you're not going to charge money
uh to record your talk multiple times
and then you have you can go through and
pick the one that you think is best um
and so don't don't feel like married to
having to do like one perfect take uh
it's it's very possible to do multiple
takes if you want to
cool
and then we have another question from
patrick um as for the recordings are we
meant to link a recording in the
proposal so you do not have to link a
recording of the proposal what will
happen is if your talk is accepted to
julia khan we will send out instructions
closer to the conference about how to
make your recording and how to upload it
we're gonna try and have captioning
um including in non-english languages so
uh we'll give you detailed instructions
about how to deal with that um closer to
the conference but you only need to
worry about making a recording um if
slash one your talk is accepted um and
we also don't so for some proposal types
like for birds of a feather or for
workshops we don't use pre-submitted
recordings those are live broadcasts so
depending on the type of proposal you're
submitting you may or may not need to
make a recording at all
yeah and i think we actually forgot one
in here again by martin could you tell
us something about julia's proceedings
so um as some of you might know um when
you are when you are when you're giving
a talk or workshop at julia con you have
the possibility to submit an article to
the julia
to the juliacom proceedings and um that
article will basically be uh yeah
basically published as an as an open
source oh sorry that's actually it
builds an open source software but
listen it's an open access journal which
um which
yeah the proposal committee runs in
collaboration with the uh
what are the name these these yeah
basically we're the people behind the
journal of open source software so
there's a collaboration sorry
do you know the name
no no i was agreeing with you it's the
folks behind jars yeah exactly it's the
folks behind jaws it's their software so
it's it's really again false open source
and um yeah so that is basically the
possibility you have and the way it
works is
more or less like in any standard
journal so you write up a small pdf
document based on a i think a markdown
latex
type type type setting and then you
submit it to github as a pull request so
that's the part which is bit different
from standard software um sorry from
standard journals and then it's sort of
the review process goes on in github as
a pull request and basically when the
pull request gets merged meaning when
the review is over then your your paper
gets automatically uh published and
that's more or less how it works so if
you give a talk you can
um you can
submit such a such a search paper the
review goes through and
cool
i actually didn't mean to post that to
all of them people in the pi data chat
are going to be like what on earth
where did that come from anyway it's
saturday morning so
and as you can see i'm still working on
my copy so
that's my excuse
all right
feel free to shoot more questions
absolutely
so i guess this is a follow-up by alex
on the on the question of joss who is
his force as this uh julia kong
proceedings so uh he and the question is
do we need to submit papers along the
talk uh and basically the answer is no
so the way it works with these juliacom
proceedings is that once the conference
is completely over you have a few months
so i don't remember the exact time but
it's usually not instantly it's it's you
have a few months to write up the paper
and then to submit the paper and
typically um it's let's say these two
months
extend quite a bit in the sense that it
usually takes quite some time until
everything is over with reviews and so
on and so forth so i don't think there's
a really hard deadline on this if i
remember so um yeah basically it's not
instantly you have some time to prepare
them too
logan asked will there be a juliacon
podcast this year and he votes yes um
so this is a bit of an unfair question
because logan is also helping to
organize the conference so i agree there
should be a julia khan podcast this year
and i also vote for logan organizing it
thanks logan for volunteering
yeah i'm also in favor of that
uh
patrick has another one uh can we
somehow express preference for which
proposal which proposal is most
important to us
um
i i mean i would say
you can in the sense that you just put
put a note on on the on the proposal
text
um however i mean in the end if the
proposal gets accepted of course you're
not forced to do the presentation right
so for example if there's like two or
three proposals which get accepted you
can still afterwards decide for yourself
okay this is the one i'm actually going
to do and this is the one that i don't
want to do i mean you can always get in
touch like when this happens in the end
that you have multiple accepted
proposals and ask us what like what do
we what we think which one you should do
or something like that so
that is yeah there's no real pressure in
that sense
i mean you can also just give multiple
talks too
uh especially like like nobody's i mean
you're not paying by the minute to to
upload like these youtube videos so
the more the merrier imo it's always
good to have more talks rather than
fewer
so if you feel after recording multiple
times i would i would just suggest doing
it um
exactly that yeah that's true
um and then we have another question
from alex about birds of a feather how
much organization do birds of a feather
groups need are they they're more
informal talks correct um so for anybody
who's not familiar birds of a feather
are like interest group meetings um so
they actually need very little
organization uh so basically what you
need to organize a bath a birds of a
feather is a time that you want the box
to be held and a topic that it's going
to be about and then maybe like the
names of one or two people to host it so
when you have a bath it's literally just
like a bunch of people gathering in a
chat room to discuss the topic of the
buff so for example we've had
like gpu computing buffs that tim basard
and valentine sravy organized in
previous years and it's just everybody
piles into like a discord chat room and
just discusses gpus and the organizers
are in charge of like muting people if
they talk too much um and that's about
it uh and we just want you to submit a
time zone this year because we want like
for example if people want to have a
boss about
the
julia lying community in their country
and their country you know is like in an
asia pacific time zone then it makes
sense for that buff to occur at a time
that's convenient for everybody in that
time zone i.e not like three in the
morning local time um so we just want to
make sure that we'll be able to schedule
the buff at a time that makes sense um
so all you really need to do is be like
like i want to have a bath about this
topic
um here's the the organizers of the buff
at this time and then maybe write a few
sentences about like why this would be a
good bop to have it's it's completely
fine to have one about like you know the
community in your country or your
language or like a specific
sort of topic
that you work in so for example like
like bioinformatics and julia would be a
great buff um so buffs are are not very
intense to organize um
we basically just show up on time to run
the run this session that's it
yeah that generally meant to sort of
like jump start a discussion or
jumpstart like a agglomeration of a sub
community inside julia and i guess what
is helpful is to sort of think of a few
leading questions to get the to get the
whole discussion going and i mean if you
want to talk about multiple things that
are sort of related under a topic to
sort of structure a little bit how much
time you want to spend on things so yeah
i think that's pretty much it
um so martin has another question do we
know if next year's truly account will
be virtual physical i think the short
answer is no
um
we'll probably have to decide that
closer to the
so and of course that'll be next year's
committee deciding this too um yeah i
mean it depends you know completely
unlike what the covenant travel
situation is like so
i mean
this far into the pandemic i don't want
to make any guesses about what happens
so
yeah of course i mean everybody would
like to meet in person so if possible
then this
will at least be taken into account i
would say i mean it's not that virtual
this is the not new default for julia
corn i would i would not i'm not
expecting that personally but again i
mean we'll see what happens next year
yeah so martin is also thrown in hybrid
could be an interesting option
so in fact actually we have discussed
this a little bit this year whether we
would do hybrid or not and decided to
sort of settle on this idea of local
meetups um as sort of a compromise um
but the reason is mostly that hybrid is
surprisingly tricky to organize so you
have to really
especially because we really wanted this
year to to have the ability to of people
to join really from all over the world
because the problem is as soon as you go
hybrid you're sort of locking into a
time zone to some extent and that makes
it actually quite tricky for people to
really join in one conference
and this year with the virtual option we
really have the flexibility to sort of
have the conference run simultaneously
in multiple time zones
at the same time and that's sort of been
the tipping point for us to to move from
hybrid towards fully virtual
uh oh
sorry i just did this right after you
showed it so right now again where can i
find info about the local meetups
specifically the locations where they
will happen
um
so right now we don't have any specific
locations because we need people like
locally based in each spot that a meetup
could happen to organize it because like
for example if you want to have a meet
up in like buenos aires i mean you know
the julia account committee does not
know
great places to have a meet up there um
since none of us are based in buenos
aires subway um or you know like mexico
city or
um i think we probably have someone in
berlin but like you know if you want to
have a local meet up um in like
reykjavik also like i mean
we don't know where the best plot is in
reggae viktor vita um so we're we're
looking for local partners like local
members of the julia community to be
like to step up and say like hey i'm
willing to call this pizza place and
have them
put the stream on tv or just not you
know not even just hang out and talk
about julia um so if that's something
that interests you just like you know
finding a spot and getting some folks
together like advertising hey we're
gonna be at this day this time in this
spot in our city uh please reach out
because again to the organizing
committee um
because we would love to have that
happen uh
yeah and we may be able to offer like
some you know small financial support
for that too just so yeah folks can get
pizza or something so
um
basically the short answer is the local
meetups will happen where we can find
people to volunteer to organize them so
if you want to have a local meetup in
your city volunteer to organize
yeah and i guess there will be some sort
of an overview somewhere on the
conference website as time gets closer
to the conference
i hope i'm not promising too much but
i'm pretty sure
so logan asked whether there will be
julia con socks this year
that's a new one for me
do you know anything about this
um so we have discussed various options
for swag this year uh i cannot confirm
or deny the question about socks
although i really hope we do get socks
because i love socks
um
again if anybody has any suggestions for
swag you really want email the
organizing committee because that way we
can viciously pure pressure the person
who charges swag to get us this fight
that we want
um so i strongly encourage people to
engage in voter fraud by constantly
emailing the organizing committee about
how we need socks
um yeah and so we
patrick already just said that he would
buy it so we would at least have two
people with uk synthetic oh i would i
would buy like so many socks like
it would be unreasonable that you want
to do like
this you would
truckload right so just for you it would
be worth it
a lifetime supply come on exactly
so
yeah of course i mean you can also use
this youtube chat now to make cool
suggestions so alex is just suggested to
have a julia con branded waffle irons
which i think is actually a really nice
idea
you gotta get the yeah you gotta impress
in the waffle though like the julia logo
yeah exactly now exactly but i guess
shipment could quite could be quite
expensive you know like a t-shirt or
socks is reasonable but a waffle iron is
quite heavy
but i mean it would it would be worth it
right a lifetime of julia waffles
yeah well until the vault line breaks
then you gotta fix it
uh so martin has another question have
you published in julia's proceedings if
so could you tell us about your
experience so i personally have not
michael have you
yeah i have um we did it i think two
years ago with our dfdk paper it was
actually it was probably the best review
experience i've had in all my scientific
papers i mean just the fact that you
really i mean quite literally you make a
git repository you put the text files in
you you publish it on github you open a
pull request and that is your paper
submission i mean that is really
quite amazing so the whole system the
whole
um the whole um yeah machinery behind it
is that really has personally has
surprised me a lot in a positive sense
and
i mean the reviews were really nice in
the sense that it's also again public
everybody can see it um
it was really constructive feedback
because yeah it was basically
assessing our software so people have
actually opened issues in our repository
as a result of that the reviewers have
done that so it was really quite
productive and constructive also
with respect to to the to the whole
ecosystem of software that we have built
and um yeah i really enjoyed the
experience and writing it was um
yeah i mean writing a paper is writing a
paper i mean you have to sit down and
actually think about the story and so on
but it was a lot of fun and overall i
would really recommend people to do it
it took a bit of time until the reviews
were done and it was finally published
so
um yeah but i mean that's sort of the
way it is i guess people people doing
this in their free time don't always
follow up instantly through emails or
something like that but yeah
the waffle ideas are getting more and
more crazy
just want to highlight this fractal
waffles
it's really fun one
uh so we have another question from
nicholas if a talk is rejected as a
lightning talk can it be reconsidered or
moved to another category um so in
general yes so we we do have the
opportunity um
to move talks that we think would fit
one category to another so an example of
how this could happen is like if you
submit for a lightning talk which is
shorter
and people look at your proposal and
you're like and then you say this is a
great proposal but it like this is not
going to fit in a 10 minute talk so why
don't we make this a 30 minute talk and
then you can decide like okay that's
fine i'm willing to record myself and
maybe my co-presenter is talking for 30
minutes or you can say like like no
thanks i'll try and cut some material um
so it's definitely possible for us to
suggest that your talk not be a
lightning talk or vice versa that your
talk would be a better fit as a
lightning talk versus a 30-minute talk
um
so it's yeah it's definitely possible
for us to consider changing the
categories of talks
so
so the waffle idea has took off logan is
uh
yeah logan logan is currently in the in
the depths of the internet
trying to find like some waffle
distributor what we need is like the um
like a movable type but for waffles
like where you can move the the letters
but in this case you know the pattern
generators
uh does it exist
i have no idea i'm just saying it's jody
says so it could be a business
has a makerspace membership get on it
exactly
so we have another question from martin
are you guys giving taxes here so i
personally am not submitting a talk um
just because i think i'm going to be
busy enough both with my actual day job
and then also conference organizing
that i will not want to be giving a talk
um
and yeah that's me uh michael are you
planning to submit a talk this year um
yes and no i mean so we are
like as part of the the atomic structure
and molecular simulation sub group of
julia we are sort of thinking about
having a
a workshop so there's some organization
in the back going on that i'm not super
super involved with but
they they asked me to give a talk and if
if it gets accepted then i'll probably
do that but
that's going to be before the conference
hopefully so a little bit less
stressful but otherwise i will not do
much
um
uh so we have a message from joseph
who's interested in setting up a meetup
for julia khan so that's awesome um so
yeah we we have someone here to
coordinate that um by here i mean on the
organizing committee uh so let me just
very quickly um
just pull up uh
yeah so if you are interested in
organizing a local meetup
um
okay i'm just gonna send this to all of
the chats um
i'm gonna paste the email address for
the committee um
yeah please email us on the on the
organizing committee um just so uh we
can keep track of like who wants to
organize something and where and we can
keep in touch with you and figure out
just like what you would need from from
from our side to support you to organize
the meetup but that's super exciting
thank you thank you for volunteering
joseph
and just to repeat what we said right in
the beginning if you're also interested
in reviewing proposals that is also an
excellent opportunity to give something
back to the community also please reach
out and let us know especially for
reviewers in non-english languages as
we're allowing non-english submissions
for the first time this year and
probably have quite a bit of a shortage
of people in that category
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
uh
ah martin has another follow-up uh when
will we receive
a notification whether the talk accept
is accepted or not so
um basically when the talks are
submitted we will send them to revenue
committee
and do two or three depending a little
bit on on how the results is uh i think
no two rounds of revenues right is
something that we discussed yeah and so
after that we will come back to you with
the results so it's really
we hope to do it as soon as possible as
always but um as i said people are doing
this in their free time so sometimes it
just takes a little bit of
time to to just get back to you
so i'm finding it hard to give you a
definitive answer here but um yeah i
don't know i haven't been on the
committee in the past year so how long
does this usually take
um so
my recollection last year was that
people got answers back in about a month
but
um
yeah i would have said the same but i
don't really remember
so yeah
try to convince my cat to come on stream
doesn't want to be a big movie stuff
apparently not
[Music]
you can definitely hear it making sounds
yeah
come on
laura everyone to see your fluffy tail
everybody wants to see your fluffy tail
she's not interested she doesn't listen
to me
where are you going to send me to julia
come on talk
[Music]
call that as a yes
that's her complaining about time to
first plot
just getting annoyed and not know that i
know that
exactly it's because i'm not paying
attention
you're trying very hard though i know i
know
while i try to test my cat does anybody
have any more questions
there we go
let me see the tail exactly
hey hey little miss
do you want to paint
briefly address very briefly exactly
all right nicholas has another one what
opportunities will there be for formal
discussions uh informal discussions
after the talks so basically what we
will set up um
this year as in the previous virtual
years as basically a discord or a
similar type of system to yeah
accommodate the possibility to ask
questions via chat during the talk and
then of course also keep discussing
about the talk and other topics that
could have come up in julia conn
during the
during the
discussions
yeah and basically you can keep chatting
and this is sort of the opportunity for
informal discussions
and um same as in the previous years we
also plan to have like a gather town or
something along those lines um at the
end of each julia con today
somehow
arranged like that which is just going
to be an opportunity to informally meet
in the virtual world and chat a little
bit about julia or whatever comes up
um yeah
uh so we have a question from modern
solutions what did i stumble into here
so this is the uh the q a
um
relaxed conversation about the juliacon
2022 cfp featuring a cameo by one of my
cats
so uh if if you're interested please
submit a proposal to julia khan 2022.
yeah we don't get maybe more cat cameos
so
so
yeah i don't have a cat so if people ask
for more cats that means kate you have
to convince your cats again
uh so we have another question from
modern solutions do you have more than
enough proposals are you desperately
trying to fill slots
um
so i don't say we're desperately trying
to fill slots uh but it's always nice to
have more people submit talks because
the conference is fully virtual this
year there's really no limit on the
number of talks we can have which is
actually a good situation to be in
because it means we can accept talks
that are
um high quality which most submissions
usually are
without having to worry about who we
have to cut because of space constraints
so um if you're interested in submitting
a talk whether you're a newcomer to
julia or an expert um i would say just
go for it um
in general um yeah we usually get like
quite a few proposals which is
awesome um and it's always exciting to
see what people are working on so
uh yeah um i wouldn't say there there's
a situation where we can have like too
many proposals so if you're at all
interested please submit
yeah especially because this year we we
really i mean as i said with this idea
to to address people from communities
all around the world with different
languages and so on we will very likely
not have the schedule where there is a
sort of a fixed block where all the
talks are scheduled to come live on
youtube or like maybe multiple blocks
which are really spread out um
accommodating different time zones and
therefore um i think this year we are
sort of more tentatively looking for
more talks uh to really spread out over
this whole this whole program
so yeah please more proposals
and then we had another question from
harlan is there a list of tax proposals
so that but when we've gone through the
review process we'll release this year's
list of accepted talks and proposals if
you're interested in seeing uh in
previous years what kind of talks have
been given to julia khan all the
programs for previous juliacons are
available online at juliacon.org so if
you are interested kind of in like the
style that people write their abstracts
in or
the kind of talks that tend to get
accepted definitely check previous
year's programs and that should give you
a good idea of the kind of talks that we
usually have julicon so from the cfp
there are actually links directly to the
to the websites of previous jubilee
accounts and from there you can directly
find access refine the talks in the top
lists
uh and martin that's another question
would it be possible to spend the same
talking two languages and would this be
interesting for you guys uh so the
answer is yes to both it's very possible
to submit the same talk in multiple
languages so for example if you'd like
to give your talk in english and then
also in another language or in two
non-english languages that you speak um
that's very encouraged that would be
awesome to see um so again please just
note in your proposal when you submit
that you would be interested in giving
the talk in multiple languages and list
what those languages are um and that way
we can you know tag the talk with the
appropriate languages and get native
speakers of the language uh to try and
review it um
and also uh try and perhaps have a
native speaker of the language the talk
has given in to moderate the question
chat
um so yeah that's that's definitely
encouraged just please let us know in
the proposal that that's like that's
what you want to do
and then modern solutions has another
one uh how is one supposed to treat
things which are still working progress
and no idea how to shake out so i think
for that um well first of all
if it's sort of a
if it sort of points to a problem that
might be part of like language or part
of your design that you would consider
worth
sharing with the rest of the community
then i think also
talks which really point towards
problems or not unsolved stuff is really
highly appreciated i don't think that
necessarily a talk should always present
a solution to a problem sometimes
presenting the problem by itself could
also be worth um and then secondly sort
of if it's more really like a
work in progress idea this this to me
sounds very much what lightning talks
are also for to to get people interested
into stuff you're working on maybe to
get people to actually start working
with you on the topic sort of to find
collaborators and for example if there's
a birds of feather which sort of fits
the topic that could also be a good
point to reach out to and just
sort of find further people to really
get going on a particular topic
oh and yeah and of course there to some
extent experiences are also meant for
this right so people who
sort of start to get into a project and
um stumble across
across a yeah sort of across a
a problem i think in the experience
could also be a good point to really
reach out and
present it
cool so we've been going for about uh an
hour
so if anybody has any last-minute
questions they want to get in um now's
the time
um and we'll also be available both on
slack and discourse and at least in my
case twitter so if you think of a
burning question you have after this
ends please feel free to ask it in any
of those venues too
um
so uh modern solutions has a question
about jump we'll jumpy a pop this year
so it's definitely possible we could
have a bar focused on jump but jump also
has their own conference track this year
so they're accepting i think basically
all the same types of
conference submissions that the main
julia con
cfp is um so if you want to organize a
jump off or ask other people to organize
one that's great too but you can also
submit jump specific talks if that's
something you're interested in doing
so then nicholas asked about these buff
sessions that i've been mentioning and
whether they're sort of a later
submission deadline so um yeah maybe
this was not a good way to phrase it so
typically you can or people might submit
a birds of feather a proposal for a
topic that fits you and then if this
gets accepted you can reach out to the
organizers of this birds or feather
session to to see if you can basically
engage with the discussion and see what
they have planned and so on and so forth
so typically birds of a feather sessions
are really also around to jumpstart the
development around a certain topic
um but i mean as of now they are also
not yet known of course there could be
potentially um if like your particular
problems of broader interest that could
for example be the opportunity to submit
a birds of a feather and sort of get
started on a discussion on that topic
with the rest of the people
so modern solution asks if the jump cfp
is different
um
yeah not really actually because jump
uses exactly the same submission system
as we do but the the review and the
program uh organization is done by
yeah basically it's sort of a separate
track and the organization and the
review process is a bit different i mean
not different it's it's following the
same review stages but the the whole
organization of the program is separate
from from the main of jupiacon
so cfp is the same review is pretty much
the same but then organization of the
program is a different story
cool
so i guess it's been an hour um so
thanks everybody who attended and
watched and asked questions um good luck
with your proposals and hopefully we'll
see you all virtually at least with
juliacount
yeah looking forward to talk to all to
you virtually
bye bye everyone have a great weekend